the best messages in any given
negotiation are really implied
indirectly come to the other person
based on thinking that you're getting
them to do getting them to get some
really solid thought behind their
answers and so a great thing to send
someone in an email is have you given up
on this project because nobody likes to
give up on anything and at the same time
nobody wants to say yes to that because
they don't know what they're letting
themselves in full when they say yes you
know and it's interesting because that
particular email has restarted
negotiations that have seen dead silence
for weeks prior to that and simply
sending that email all by itself and in
many cases you can get a response within
three to five minutes over reading the
email or the text that's a great way to
get things restarted now the problem
with that is there's a really good
chance you contributed to the silence in
the first place and your next movement
when they respond is you've got to get
it that's right out of them next because
they have to feel like that their
communication is being paid attention to
a summary is designed to let the other
side know that you really understand
what's going on now and if nothing else
at least you understand their position
there are a lot of negotiators that
really will give in on a deal because
being understood is more important than
getting what they want
in particular the assertive negotiator
being understood is actually more
important to them than actually making
the deal so everybody wants to be
understood anyway let people know you
completely understand where they're
coming from and that's the design of a
summary summarizing the facts and how
they feel about the facts and actually
if you can summarize their feelings
about the facts that are driving them
but that they're blind to will make a
big difference to them because then they
feel really understood that
but the connection is there and they may
actually change their mind about what
decisions they've made
once the empathise have been established